[Music]
Google just gave Israel super dystopian
artificial intelligence technology to
identify and keep track of Palestinians
kinda like how IBM gave the Germans
Punch Cards to identify and keep track
of Jews in World War II and this AI
technology may be coming to a town near
you this is gonna be a controversial one
so you're Israel the Palestinians think
this land is rightfully theirs and so do
you so you and the Palestinians have
been fighting over this piece of land
for the past 75 years I personally have
no stance on this issue either way feel
free to fight each other in the comments
section below because of all this
conflict you've put the Palestinians
under Mass surveillance and security we
have 22 checkpoints well more than 100
movement barriers we have 1800 shops
closed by the Israeli closure policy we
have around 1 000 Palestinian Apartments
became empty so the area where I usually
do my activities and where Palestinians
are suffering is very very restricted
and maybe you will see a soldier every
two to three meters and border cities
like Hebron cameras are everywhere some
sample has stopped letting their kids
play in the yard in fear of Israel's
All-Seeing Eye one former Soldier said
the cameras can even see into private
homes every few meters you see uh one
camera or two cameras or three cameras
so the people don't feel
you know any kind of purpose even inside
their homes in Hebron but then you run
into a problem you have a ton of cameras
to monitor you would need soldiers
Around the Clock watching terabytes of
footage to look out for suspicious
activity to keep track of who's who to
see what people are up to and that is
simply not practical so who do you turn
to Google who's got the best AI Tech out
there and is always drooling at the
mouth for profitable government
contracts so when you went to Google
Google happily accepted they went all
out for the Israelis now instead of
people having to manually monitor these
cameras Google's AI will be able to
automatically track names faces and
locations of Palestinians now that is
cool but it's not all that special what
is special is that on top of that
Google's AI will apparently be able to
determine people's emotional states this
is according to training documents made
for the Israeli government which
includes a section called settlement
analysis that means if the AI detects
someone looking say extra angry or
vengeful today why not stop him at the
next security checkpoint in the name of
safety in the name of preventing crime
from happening pre-crime after all
expressing emotions is dangerous this
will turn the areas near the Palestinian
border into highly patrolled smart War
zones nothing could go wrong here right
governments are definitely not going to
see Israel using this Tech and want to
eventually use it themselves right stay
dangerous and let's get into it
[Music]
Israel is a super polarizing topic which
leads to some insane bias in the media
coverage about it take this story about
Israel for example nearly 70 percent of
the sources for the story were
left-leaning but when you look at this
story about how Putin might have cancer
most of the sources lean rights and when
you take it a step further and look at
who owns the media companies that report
on the story none of them are
independently owned they're all owned by
super rich people or giant media
conglomerates and the only reason I'm
able to know all this is because of
ground news ground news is super cool
it's a website and app that shows you
the latest breaking news stories how
biased the coverage is left-leaning
right-leaning or in the middle how
accurate and factual the sources are a
breakdown of who owns the media
companies covering the story and you can
even swipe between headlines to see how
the exact same story is framed
differently by left Center and right
sources like this story about Kanye
being back on Instagram the right
leading headline makes it sound positive
Kanye is seemingly defiant offering no
apologies while the left ones aren't so
positive saying he returns amid
continued Fallout and that's what I love
about ground news it allows you to break
free from media bias so that you can
think for yourself and learn the truth
about what's going on so if you're
looking for a better way to read the
news go to ground.new slash straight
Trend to try it for free or subscribe to
get access to all the features you see
here so pause the video and go to
ground.news jtran with the link below to
get started now thanks to ground news
for sponsoring this video
foreign
[Music]
the Israeli Defense Forces launched a
program called Operation Blue Wolf and
it went a little something like this
have soldiers go out and take pictures
of Palestinians
put these pictures in your own private
version of Facebook where family history
education level and security rating is
recorded then at checkpoints scan faces
and depending on the security rating
that comes up question detain or arrest
oh and don't forget to take as many
photos as possible so you can win extra
vacation days for your unit course
as you can see having soldiers manually
spy on people is pretty inefficient so
they needed some help they have all
these security cameras already but if
they wanted their AI to be able to take
this footage and categorize specific
objects like suspicious looking
Palestinians or someone doing something
violent in the street it would take
years and a lot of money to manually
train their AI to do that because before
an AI bot can decide they're seeing
signs of violence a human needs to feed
it millions of images and videos of
people doing violent things in all kinds
of different situations even in cartoons
so it can confidently know what a
violent act actually looks like but
Israel just doesn't have the time to
wait for a whole staff of human
technicians to feed the AI footage and
then manually tag photos for them they
need the automatic surveillance now so
where will the Israeli government get
all this footage to train their AI
software from Google Google's cloud is
really a match made in heaven when you
think about it and once their AI
software is hooked up to Google platform
Israel will be able to go from zero to
1984 in a matter of months enter project
nimbus
[Music]
in April 2021 the Israeli finance
ministry announced that Google signed a
contract to build a 1.2 billion dollar
cloud computing system called project
Nimbus giving the Israeli government
full access to Google's machine learning
and AI tools and that this shouldn't be
too big of a deal I mean in 2020
America's border patrol used Google's AI
Cloud platform to analyze footage from
their surveillance Towers why can't the
Israelis but there's something different
about project Nimbus if you take a look
at the AI training documents Google gave
to the Israeli government you will see
that they show instructions on how to
use their cloud of data for emotional
detection where the AI would look at
facial movement speech and even text to
determine the emotional state of a
subject as you can see it can detect a
joy sorrow anger surprise exposed
whatever that means or if the image is
blurred or if the subject is wearing
headwear which is probably referring to
something like this
Google's AI also gives its Choice a
confidence score in this case 53 percent
you will also notice that the training
documents contain a custom logo that
combines Google with the Israeli flag
suggesting that Israel is being given
their own separate Cloud platform for
perhaps more military driven goals but
of course Google refused to comment when
asked about this by The Intercept but
here's the problem AI emotion detection
can get a little dicey even Microsoft
who has their own little AI Cloud
platform said that it would no longer
offer a motion detection features
because it just isn't accurate enough
critics say that it's unscientific to
assume that the expression you make
reflects what you're really feeling
inside because everyone can fake a smile
there have also been studies done on the
accuracy of emotional detection through
AI
one study said that emotional detection
tends to assign more negative emotions
to certain ethnicities Institute of
Standards and Technology founded the
facial recognition technology suffers
from a significant bias that leads to
misidentifications of minorities it
violates our rights to be free from
surveillance to privacy and of course
say to preserve some anonymity without
privacy we cannot really be free right
but Google just doesn't seem worried
about
as long as the money is good they're
completely okay with deploying this Tech
into a conflict Zone
[Music]
this is Hebron a city that is now a
ghost town it's located right on the
border of Israel and Palestine and
because both Palestinians and Israelis
live there soldiers are constantly
policing the area we have 22 checkpoints
more than 100 movement barriers we have
1800 shops closed by the israeliac
closure policy here there is no concept
of personal privacy and the people who
live there are constantly being
monitored whether it's through
checkpoints
[Music]
getting your house searched getting
yourself searched getting detained no
matter what your age
bomb as a sheep
[Music]
oh and don't forget to smile
the level of surveillance and control in
the city of Hebron has been slowly
ramping up over the years but civilians
are now noticing a whole new level to
the Israeli military's presence there
are cameras everywhere Mountain on
houses on street corners some people
have stopped letting their kids play in
the yard in fear of the Army's
All-Seeing Eye one former Soldier said
that the cameras can even see into
private homes
some Palestinians are convinced it's a
way to drive them out of the West Bank
so that Israel can finally get the land
they've been wanting for centuries
others see it as a weird dystopian
experiment a testing ground for
surveillance technology that can later
be sold to other countries it's a kind
of using the Palestinians as a
simulation object it's a kind of you
know you know we are an experiment so
they are trying to kiss this new
technology on the Palestinians
especially in Hebrew then they sell it
to Kashmir they sell it to India they
sell it I don't know where
foreign
[Music]
Google has been trying to get big fat
dystopian government contracts for years
there was Project Maven in 2017 where
they tried to sell their Drone footage
to the US military project dragonfly in
2018 where they tried to build a
censored search engine for China but
every time they get close to making a
deal some annoying ungrateful Google
employee tries to expose all their hard
work so how did Google finally get away
with it this time in the case of Israel
Google's ethical AI Charter states that
they will not quote deploy AI that
causes or is likely to cause overall
harm including weapons surveillance or
any application whose purpose
contravenes widely accepted principles
of international law and human rights
end quote all right sounds good sounds
Noble but wait read the fine print in
Google's contract with Israel and you'll
see that Israel put in a clause that
conveniently blocks Google from being
able to drop the project even if there's
protests I guess Google made sure that
their employees won't be able to
dismantle yet another lucrative
government contract
here's another convenient detail
2018
the CEO of Google put out a blog post
saying that Google would not develop
artificial intelligence for quote
weapons or other Technologies whose
principal purpose or implementation is
to cause or directly facilitate injury
to people end
so instead Google invests in startups
that do the dirty work for them
companies like orbital and planning
which work directly with the US defense
department on projects that could be
said to quote directly facilitate injury
end quote so Google is involved in
plenty of sketchy government contracts
you just don't know about it because
it's not directly tied to their name but
it's not all Google Israel is an equal
player in this scheme any Vision an
Israeli tech company which created the
facial recognition software the Army
uses at Hebron City checkpoints claim
that their technology was only being
used to authenticate the workers as they
pass through but a leaked demo video
obtained by NBC news showed that people
were actually being recognized and
tracked as they walked the streets not
just at the checkpoints the Israeli
Association of civil rights also
recently found out that the police have
been using license plate recognition
technology to track the movement of cars
in Israel they started using this
technology a few years ago without any
official clearance by the law and now
the government is in the process of
creating new legislation to allow the
police to legally use this tracking
software as well as facial recognition
on regular Israeli citizens all in the
name of safety right
and as Israel perfects this Mass
surveillance technology on the
Palestinian populace what's stopping
them from eventually selling this
technology to other interested
governments just look at Israel's
Pegasus spyware this spyware allows you
to hack into almost any phone read your
Target's text messages track calls track
their location collect passwords turn on
their microphone and Camera all without
your victim ever having to click on
anything and Israel's cyber Arms Company
NSO group has sold the spyware to
powerful people all over the world to
allow them to spy on activists
journalists and political leaders and
the like
it was even used by the Crown Prince of
Saudi Arabia to hack into Jeff bezos's
phone so don't be surprised if in the
future governments start buying Israel's
new emotion detection as a service
package and it's all thanks to Google
maybe it's convenient that Google
removed their company-wide motto don't
be evil from their code of conduct
documents in 2018 a phrase that has been
a part of the company's code of conduct
since the very start
Israel and Palestine are fighting over
land a conflict as old as Humanity
itself in the medieval times land owners
were considered Lords because they had
all the power all the soldiers all the
wealth but lucky for you today you too
can be a lord thanks to established
titles if you're not familiar with
established titles it allows you to buy
approximately one square foot of land in
Scotland for just under fifty dollars
and the thing about owning land in
Scotland is that there is an old
Scottish tradition where land owners are
called lards and ladies that means for
just under fifty dollars you can put
that your lord on your credit cards on
your plane tickets dating profiles and
more to show that you are above the
peasantry to be clear this is not an
official warship it is still pretty cool
you're gonna get a certificate it will
feature a unique plot number for your
plot of land in Scotland these make a
super unique last minute GIF that would
definitely set you apart from everyone
else's mediocre gifts there's an
exclusive sale going off for viewers of
this channel where you'll get 10 off any
purchase when you go to establish
titles.com jaketran and use code jtran
so pause the video and become a lord
today by going to established house.com
and using code jtran with the link below
thanks to established titles for
sponsoring this video
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]